TO BAR BARR.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
WE'VE ALL HEARD THE CRITICISMS
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHICH GOES
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
>> NO PRESIDENT HAS COME CLOSE
TO DEFAMING AND TRYING TO
DESTROY THE DEMOCRATIC VALUES OF
THIS COUNTRY.
NO PRESIDENT HAS COME CLOSE.
>> DOES HE KNOW HE'S TEARING
DOWN THESE INSTITUTIONS?
>> HE SHATTERS NORMS FOR A
LIVING.
>> HOW MUCH LONGER CAN YOU
SURVIVE THE AUTOCRATIC
TENDENCIES OF ONE MAN?
>> HE IS REVEALING HIS
AUTOCRATIC TENDENCIES.
DONALD TRUMP HAS NO REAL
COMMITMENT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: THE ONLY OTHER TEAM
IT HAS A COMMITMENT TO
DEMOCRACY, THAT IS WHY THEY ARE
TRYING TO UNDERMINE HIM.
AND UNDER THE ELECTION.
LOOK, IF ANY OF THAT WERE TRUE,
WHY ON EARTH WOULD
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOMINATE A MAN
LIKE BILL BARR AS HIS ATTORNEY
GENERAL?
BARR, NO MATTER WHAT YOU THINK,
HE'S A MAINSTREAM, SAFE PICKED.
A CONSUMMATE PRO WHO SERVED IN
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION AND
LATER AS GEORGE HW BUSH'S
COUNSEL AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BEFORE BEING PROMOTED TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
FULL DISCLOSURE, HE'S A FRIEND.
DON'T HOLD THAT AGAINST ME.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS, HE KNOWS
THE LEGAL TERRAIN REALLY WELL
AND HE EVEN OVERSAW THE
ROBERT MUELLER GUY THAT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON ONCE BEFORE, WHEN
MUELLER WAS HEAD OF DOJ'S
CRIMINAL DIVISION.
AND IF THERE IS ANY QUESTION
ABOUT BARR'S INDEPENDENCE, WELL,
THAT WAS PUT TO REST AT TODAY'S
HEARING.
>> WHAT WOULD BE HER BREAKING
POINT?
WHEN WOULD YOU PICK UP AND MADE?
WHEN IS YOUR JIM MATTIS MOMENT?
WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS ASKING YOU
TO DO SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
IS INCONSISTENT WITH YOUR OATH?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
THAT I THINK IS WRONG, AND I
WILL NOT BE BULLIED INTO DOING
ANYTHING THAT I THINK IS WRONG.
I ANYBODY, WHETHER IT BE
EDITORIAL BOARDS OR CONGRESS OR
THE PRESIDENT.
I'M GOING TO DO WHAT I THINK IS
RIGHT.
>> Laura: ALL, AND AS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC DRUMBEAT THAT TRUMP
ONLY SELECTS PEOPLE THAT HE CAN
CONTROL AND WHO ESSENTIALLY
AGREED TO, I DON'T KNOW, SOME
SORT OF LOYALTY PLEDGE...
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SOUGHT TO
NO ASSURANCES, PROMISES, OR
COMMITMENTS FOR ME OF ANY KIND,
EITHER EXPRESS OR IMPLIED, AND I
HAVE NOT GIVEN HIM ANY, OTHER
THAN THAT I WOULD RUN THE
DEPARTMENT WITH PROFESSIONALISM
AND INTEGRITY.
>> Laura: BARR TESTIFIED THAT
HE WANTS MUELLER TO COMPLETE HIS
PROBE AND HAS CONFIDENCE IN
MUELLER'S PROFESSIONALISM.
BUT THAT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR SOME,
LIKE SENATOR PAT LAHEY, WHO
TRIED TO GET BARR TO VOW TO
RECUSE HIMSELF FROM OVERSIGHT OF
THE MUELLER PROBE IF THE STAFF
AT THE DOJ SUGGESTS HE DO SO.
>> SO WILL YOU COMMIT, IF
CONFIRMED, TO BOTH SEEKING AND
FOLLOWING THE ADVICE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE CAREER ETHICS
OFFICIALS AS TO WHETHER YOU MUST
RECUSE FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION?
>> I WILL SEEK THE ADVICE OF THE
CAREER ETHICS PERSONNEL, BUT
UNDER THE REGULATIONS, I MAKE
THE DECISION AS THE HEAD OF THE
AGENCY AS TO MY OWN RECUSAL.
SO I CERTAINLY WOULD CONSULT
WITH THEM AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY, I WOULD MAKE A DECISION IN
GOOD FAITH BASED ON THE LAWS AND
THE FACTS THAT ARE EVIDENT AT
THAT TIME.
>> Laura: I'M SORRY, WE ARE
ALL SITTING HERE IN THE STUDIO.
HE REMINDS ME SO MUCH OF JUSTICE
SCALIA, HIS INFLECTION, THE WAY
HE REACTS TO QUESTIONS.
IT JUST BROUGHT IT BACK.
IT WAS ODD.
ANYWAY, IT'S CLEAR THAT BARR HIS
OWN MAN.
CONTRARY TO SOME OTHER NASTY
TWEETS, TWEETS FROM THE RIGHT
LIKE THIS.
"I DON'T TRUST BARR.
HE SEEMS AWFULLY COZY WITH THE
MANY OF THE PEOPLE SURROUNDING
THE WHOLE SPYGATE SCANDAL."
I GET THE CONCERN.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT I HAVE
KNOWN BARR FOR 20 PLUS YEARS.
HE'S A MAN OF DEEP INTEGRITY.
HE HAS A REALLY STRONG INSTINCT.
WE NEED THAT AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
HE COMES AT A VERY IMPORTANT
TIME IN THE LIFE OF ALL OF THESE
LAW-ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AGENCIES.
HE SEES HIS JOB, IN WHAT I THINK
IS THE CORRECT LIGHT.
>> WHAT DO WHY DO YOU WANT TE
>> WHAT DO WHY DO YOU WANT TJ
>> WHAT DO WHY DO YOU WANT TB
>> WHAT DO WHY DO YOU WANT T?
>> BECAUSE I LOVE THE
DEPARTMENT, AND ALL ITS
COMPONENTS, INCLUDING THE FBI.
I THINK THEY ARE CRITICAL
INSTITUTIONS.
THAT ARE CENTRAL TO PRESERVING
THE RULE OF LAW,
WHICH IS THE HEARTBEAT OF THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: HE'S DOING IT
BECAUSE HE LOVES THE COUNTRY.
IT DOESN'T NEED TO DO THAT, 68
YEARS OLD, HE COULD BE LAYING ON
THE BEACH SOMEWHERE.
HE WANTS TO SERVE THE NATION.
BILL BARR COULD NOT ASSUME THIS
DROP OF DROP OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
FAST ENOUGH, ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE REVELATIONS OF THE FBI'S
WAR AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, JUST LAST FRIDAY WE
LEARNED ABOUT ANOTHER SICKENING
EFFORT BY CERTAIN BAD ACTORS
INSIDE THE BUREAU TO TARGET THE
PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, AFTER PETER STRZOK'S
INSURANCE POLICY FAILED TO
PREVENT TRUMP FOR MINING THE
WHITE HOUSE, JAMES COMEY'S FBI
CRONIES PULLED ANOTHER SURPRISE
OUT OF ITS BAG OF TRICKS.
THEY LAUNCHED AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
UNPRECEDENTED COUNTER INTEL
INVESTIGATION OF THE SITTING
PRESIDENT.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE FIRED, AT
LEAST THOSE WHO ARE STILL
WORKING WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS SUPPOSEDLY
DONE -- GET THIS -- BECAUSE
TRUMP FIRED COMEY.
WHICH, OF COURSE, IF THEY
BROUGHT THEIR POCKET
CONSTITUTION, THE PRESIDENT WAS
FULLY ENTITLED TO DO UNDER
ARTICLE TWO OF THE CONSTITUTION.
NOW THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
FINAL REPORT SHOULD EXPOSE ALL
OF THIS.
CAN'T WAIT.
AND AS OF THINGS COULD NOT GET
MORE POISONOUS, WE LEARNED
TODAY THAT THE FORMER
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE THE FBI,
JAMES BAKER, HIMSELF WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR MEDIA LEAKS
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TURNS OUT, HE WAS IN REGULAR
CONTACT WITH "MOTHER JONES"
LEFTIST WRITER DAVID CORN.
ARE THEY STILL PUBLISHING?
IT'S JUST A COINCIDENCE, I'M
SURE.
REMEMBER, IT WAS THE FIRST TO
REPORT ON THAT PHONY STEELE
DOSSIER, THAT THING THAT WAS A
PREDICATE USED TO START THE
ENTIRE TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE.
BARR UNDERSTANDS THE DANGER
INHERENT IN A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT BECOMES ITS OWN
POLITICAL STRIKE FORCE.
AND THE DANGER OF CRIMINALIZING
POLITICS AND OF OVERZEALOUS
PROSECUTORS.
>> THE PROSECUTOR COMES ALONG
AND SAYS, WELL, WE'LL LOOK INTO
YOUR MIND AND SEE WHAT YOU YOUR
SUBJECTIVE INTENT WAS FOR
PERFORMING THESE TWO SETS OF
LAWFUL ACTS, AND WE ARE GOING TO
SAY, YOU KNOW, THAT YOU ARE
CORRUPT.
SO I JUST THINK THAT GIVES TOO
MUCH POWER TO THE PROSECUTOR.
>> Laura: TOTALLY AGREE, EVEN
SEPARATE FROM WHAT HAS HAPPENED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF DEMOCRATS REALLY CARED, AS
THEY CLAIM, ABOUT THE RULE OF
LAW AND RESTORING THE PUBLIC
FAITH IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THEY WOULD WELCOME WITH OPEN
ARMS THE NOMINATION OF BILL
BARR.
BUT BECAUSE MANY OF THEM, NOT
ALL, BUT MANY, ARE INFECTED WITH
THIS ANTI-TRUMP VIRUS, EVERYONE
TRUMP NOMINEES, EVERY IDEA THAT
TRUMP HAS, MUST BE RESISTED,
OR THE INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED, AT